les fans comptent les jours la prochaine
édition du Japan tour festival c'est
quasiment dans une semaine les
festivités vont débuter le vendredi 30
juin 3 jours dédiés à la culture nippone
ou parc des expositions de Tours 25000
visiteurs sont attendus pour faire le
tour des 260 exposants et profitez des
600 animations programmées la nouveauté
cette année c'est l'accueil de la finale
de la Coupe de France de cosplay 29
candidats et candidates vont s'affronter
pour décrocher le titre du meilleur
costume de manga
recevoir cette Coupe de France un
honneur parce que c'est une des
c'est une compétition donc de niveau
national mais pas que les candidats vont
après concourir parfois au niveau
européen et autres donc on a un niveau
de de qualité de finition de mise en
scène pour ses concours là qui dépassent
la plupart des attentes des visiteurs en
règle générale on a on est sur des
costumes qui sont proches du cinéma
quand même
dans certains travaillent même pour des
fictions ou des séries
blanc-manger coco
ou encore Cluedo
le top 3 des jeux de société les plus
vendus en France en 2022 depuis le
confinement les jeux de société ont
retrouvé la cote auprès des adultes le
marché est florissant avec une
croissance à deux chiffres pour le
secteur preuve à l'appui elle arrivait
d'un nouveau magasin à Tours alors que
d'autres enseignes étaient déjà
présentes les la Turquie
siroter une limonade artisanale tout en
découvrant un nouveau jeu de plateau
voilà le concept du sablier curieux
cette nouvelle boutique de jeux de
société à Tours de quoi se démarquer
dans un secteur déjà très prisé je me
suis dit que c'était intéressant
peut-être de proposer quelque chose d'un
peu différent avec ce côté café ludique
voilà on peut essayer un jeu on peut
boire un verre quelque chose de faire
quelque chose de convivial c'est de
faire les choses un peu différemment
pour qu'on puisse coexister des premiers
pas dans le monde du jeu de société
quand d'autres sont déjà des
institutions sortilège Rue du Commerce à
Tours fête ses 20 ans cette année plus
de 4000 références au compteur le temps
passe et les affaires marchent toujours
aussi bien dans une boutique l'activité
plutôt bonne donc ça c'est ça c'est
chouette et agréable et puis oui on peut
le vérifier aussi puisque il y a pas mal
d'ouverture de boutiques partout sur le
territoire et elle tourne notamment
aussi un essor du jeu de société et
encore plus depuis la période du covid
la tendance ne fait que de se confirmer
même si la concurrence grandit aussi
comment les boutiques de centre-ville
persistent face aux grandes surfaces et
à l'achat en ligne je pense que la
qualité de service c'est notre cheval de
bataille on essaye enfin des vendeurs
conseils donc c'est ce qu'on essaye de
de faire au mieux transmettre notre
passion aux gens et bien comprendre
leurs besoins pour y répondre des atouts
majeurs dans ce secteur florissant avec
de la place pour tout le monde en France
environ 30 millions de boîtes de jeux
sont vendus chaque année